I remember one eight-year-old girl who cried and ran away...
...when a black teacher from Haiti showed up.
There can be a similar lack of confidence...
...when they meet people from an LGBT background.
But this little girl, she wasn't trying to discriminate.
She was just scared.
After an hour, she had become good friends with the Haitian teacher,...
...and this is the magic of children.
We all have fears.
Humans are creatures who struggle with the unexpected, unfamiliar and unknown.
Our human nature does not welcome difference.
However, I believe we humans can build a society that truly embraces diversity.
If we can change the unfamiliar to the familiar,...
...if we can change the courage to seeing differences,...
...and if we can explore the beauty of diversity,...
...then I believe we can overcome our weakness of this fear.
With all my love and respect for Japan and to One Young World, thank you.